Speaker 1: Welcome everybody, so I want to
start today by spending some time on the question
what is a woman?
And it might seem like kind of, you know,
what is a banana?
What is an apple?
It might seem kind of out of the blue, but
this is a topic that came up last week during
the confirmation hearings for Joe Biden's
Supreme Court nominee, guitar Angie Brown
Jackson, and we saw Republican Senator Marsha
Blackburn ask among a number of other bad
faith questions.
Can you give me a definition for a woman?
And here's how that went.
Speaker 2: And can you provide a definition
for the word woman?
Can I provide a definition?
Yeah.
I can't you can't.
Not this contact.
I'm not in biology,
Speaker 1: and after that all took place last
week, I appeared on the right wing Daily Wire
Show hosted by Michael Knowles, and we could
have talked about anything, but he wanted
to talk about what is a woman?
Do I have a definition for a woman?
And I explained to him that this is a bad
faith question that any answer that Judge
Jackson could have given would have allowed
Blackburn to push her into a corner about
this or that particular situation, and that
the reality is in Jackson's role as a Supreme
Court justice.
Some general definition of a woman won't really
do anything to help figure out difficult cases,
since courts have to adjudicate specific and
narrow legal issues in particular situations
based on individual complaints brought to
a court.
But now that we got that all out of the way,
I actually do want to talk about with you
what is the definition?
Because while most people understood the bad
faith nature of the question, there are people
who have reacted and who have emailed me and
have said, you know, the definition is so
easy.
But it's actually not even going by their
simple definitions, and I hope that we can
explore why this is just a bad faith, an unproductive
line of discussion and reasoning.
Now before I get into this, I do want to remind
everybody, particularly people, who might
see this segment here, this segment and not
know me.
Everything I'm saying here is my best faith
analysis of the situation, and it is with
me speaking as an unfettered defender of trans
rights who understands that this is not a
simple situation and understands the bad faith
nature of why the right keeps saying Give
us a definition for woman.
So Ryan wrote to me, and he explained, David,
here is why these things are so tough and
meaningless in the abstract.
Let's say I ask you to define life.
OK, that's pretty easy, right?
I'll look it up in the dictionary.
And let's start with the dictionary definition.
Why not?
So a dictionary definition for life is quote
life, the condition that distinguishes animals
and plants from inorganic matter, including
the capacity for growth, reproduction, functional
activity and continual change preceding death.
Great.
So now I've bought in, I've picked the definition,
and that's what Blackburn wanted.
All the Republicans wanted right was just
pick a definition and give us that definition.
But wait, a second are children, not life,
David.
Because they?
That was in your definition reproduction.
And they can't reproduce yet.
Oh, that's right, that wasn't my definition.
What about the elderly who no longer grow
and who also no longer reproduce?
No, no problem.
Let me tweak the definition.
Now I've got it, I'm going to get to it, OK?
The definition is to account for people who
are too young or too old to reproduce.
Let's have a different definition of life.
It's the condition of an organism that ever
had or will have that capability of reproduction
and growth.
Then it's life.
That's tough.
Some people are born without ever having the
capability for reproduction a man with a sperm
disorder, Klinefelter syndrome, a woman with
certain conditions.
Damn OK.
All right.
Well, let me walk it back again.
So I say what matters is the species as a
whole.
If this is a species that as a whole reproduces,
even if individual members, for whatever reason,
might not be able to, then that meets the
definition of life.
Oh no.
What about mules?
A mule is what happens when you breed a female
horse and a male donkey, and they're sterile
as a species they can't reproduce.
Mules aren't alive now based on my definition,
so you can very quickly see how this just
to fine it.
Just give us a definition.
It's not only bad faith in theory, but it's
also really tough in practice.
So now let's apply it to the question of what
is a woman during our interview.
Michael Knowles suggested a few definitions
and one of them check out the interview if
you're interested.
One definition, he said, was It's anything
and anybody that isn't a man.
Well, one point seven percent of the population
is born intersex, meaning with both genitals
or with some ambiguity in terms of the genitalia.
So if you say if it's if they're not a man,
they're a woman.
That definition doesn't account for that.
It doesn't work.
Then, Knowles said, Well, it's a human that
produces eggs.
So a lot of conditions, including hormonal
imbalances and thyroid conditions, things
in the womb, pituitary tumors that prevent
some women from producing eggs or being able
to reproduce.
Well, what about capability of reproduction
through pregnancy?
A human with the capability of reproduction
through pregnancy, tons of conditions that
inhibit reproduction.
And then you've got post-menopausal women
that can't reproduce.
But are they not women?
Very few people would argue that.
So the point here is these definitions do
not work for determining who is a woman.
Since not all biological women are able to
do these things.
Not all biological women menstruate for different
medical reasons.
Imagine defining men simply by their ability
to know, impregnate someone or have an erection.
So now let's come around to the question that
is actually underlying all of this for many
Republicans, because you have to really understand
the political angle here.
They have started to take this perspective
that anybody can simply assume an identity
and then tell a court I was discriminated
against on this basis.
And Ted Cruz kind of brought this to the absurd
during the hearings in order to make an analogy.
And Ted Cruz said, Well, could I, as a Hispanic
man for an hour, say I'm now an Asian man
and then sue Harvard for anti-Asian discrimination?
If you can say I'm a woman now, I'm a man,
why can't I say, Well, now I'm Asian?
It sounded kind of nuts.
But he said it.
And here's the clip.
Speaker 3: But the question was Let me ask.
Under the modern leftist sensibilities.
If if?
I decide right now that that I'm a woman.
Then apparently, I'm a woman, does that mean
that I would have Article three standing to
challenge a gender based restriction?
Speaker 2: Senator, to the extent that you
are asking me about who has the ability to
bring lawsuits based on gender, those kinds
of issues are working their way through the
courts and I'm not able to comment on them.
Speaker 3: OK, if I can change my gender,
if I can be a woman and then an hour later,
if I decide I'm not a woman anymore, I guess
I would lose.
Article three Standing Tell me, does that
same principle apply to other protected characteristics?
For example, I'm an asthmatic man.
Could could I decide I was an Asian man?
What I have the ability to be an Asian man
and challenge Harvard's discrimination because
I made that decision.
Speaker 2: Senator, I'm not able to answer
your question, you're asking me about hypotheticals,
and I'm
Speaker 3: asking how you would assess standing
if I if I came in and said I have decided
I identify as an Asian man,
Speaker 2: I would assess standing the way
I assess other legal issues, which is to listen
to the arguments made by the parties, consider
the relevant precedents and constitutional
principles involved and make a determination.
Speaker 1: Now, of course, we all know that
that's silly.
But why is it silly?
It's because whatever it means to be Asian,
Ted Cruz isn't actually living life as an
Asian man, which sounds a little silly when
it comes to race, but will then apply it to
gender.
And importantly, society doesn't see Ted Cruz
as an Asian man.
Now, I know you can say, but David, that's
based on stereotypes or whatever, but it gets
to something very important here when we think
about under the law.
When I think about like genitals aside, who
can bring a lawsuit for gender discrimination
because the whole idea here is they they love
to say, can a guy put a wig on and then sue
and say I was discriminated against for being
a woman?
The reality here is that when we say who can
say I was discriminated against for being
a woman, what I imagine is anyone living outwardly
as a female and seen by society as a female
could bring a lawsuit for gender discrimination.
As a woman now, I know it's not perfect, but
understand that this is the legal question.
I know Republicans love love to say, you know,
men with wigs.
There's a man with a wig hangs out in a bathroom.
They're doing all sorts of things, and the
point they make is a man with a wig, with
a wig who doesn't actually live life as a
woman, nor is seen by society as a woman.
They're going to have a very hard time showing
in court that they were discriminated against
for their status as a woman.
It's going to be very difficult to show that
now this is not about should we call people
by the pronouns they want to be called by?
Of course.
Of course, that's this is about the legal
question.
Can anybody men, women who ever say I was
discriminated and discriminated against for
being a woman?
So think about it if I put on a wig?
Right?
I wear my current clothes.
I have my current voice.
I go by the name David.
If I do all the things that socially tagged
me as male, no court is going to accept that
I was discriminated against because of the
perception that I was a woman.
I could go and do all the things right.
I could go to the DMV and say, I want to be
seen as I want to be female.
Now I want f on my license.
I could I could do all those things.
But if I sue, I'm not going to be able to
show that I was seen as a woman.
And that is paramount to proving that you
were discriminated against for gender reasons.
Now, on the other hand, if a trans woman is
seen as a woman in whatever situation they're
suing over and they can show that, why shouldn't
they be able to bring such a lawsuit?
I mean, think about it in many states, you
can be fired for your real or perceived sexual
orientation, even if you aren't a gay man.
If you're fired because your boss is homophobic
and thought you were gay, you can sue even
though you're not actually a gay man.
And similarly, the point here is when they
talk about anybody can just sue and say, I
was discriminated against because I'm a woman.
Well, can you actually show anybody believed
you were a woman in the sense of how they
related to you and their alleged discrimination?
So the big point here is when right wingers
ask this stuff.
Number one, it's obviously in bad faith.
Number two, whatever you say is going to be
used against you.
But number three, it's actually a lot more
complicated than they pretend these definitions
to be.
If we think about it from a legal standpoint
and we talk it through, we actually can make
quite a bit of headway.
So let me know your thoughts.
And hopefully we've touched on what are some
of the really underlying issues and questions
here
that
that exist?